so welcome everyone to my lightning talk
which is on IL GPU
my name is tulhagen I work for novalnet
same as pet
a Consulting Group based here in Oslo
my intention is to demonstrate
that the power of your GPU is perhaps
much more available to you
as a.net developer than you might think
Now using the GPU for general computing
has been pretty mainstream for a while
and there are several platforms
available to do this
uh the two best known ones being opencl
by the Kronos group and the Cuda
platform
by Nvidia
now
you can go in to the to the web pages
and check the documentation for these
platforms and it's pretty technical
for us.net developers in particular
it can appear somewhat inaccessible
you'll have to deal with multiple
language projects special compilers Etc
you need to use C plus plus perhaps
uh it's all a bit daunting
personally I was despairing if I would
ever get around to trying it
then I discovered ilgpu
it changes all that
The Isle GPU platform contains a
just-in-time compiler
for taking your kernel code the the code
you want to execute in parallel on the
on the accelerator and transpiling it to
the underlying GPU format
straight from the compiled.net io in
your assembly
I'll show you how that works with il GPU
you can just install a nougat package in
your.net Project
and start working
yes it really is that simple
I'll make a kind of a Hello World
project
hello world for gpus
I'll be rendering the mandelbrot set
it's just as useless as hello world but
it's much prettier and uh
and it benefits wonderfully from
parallelization as you might see
the mandelbrot set I won't get very
deeply into this but it's uh uh we need
a quick primer just so you know what
we'll be doing here uh so it's a set
it's a set of complex numbers
first investigated in the 1980s
uh it's characterized by an infinite
amount of complexity emerging from a
simple iterative function
around 1985 people realized that this
complexity can be visualized using
computers
uh it was a huge hit
because it yields some amazing imagery
and it's been the iconic example of
fractal chaos ever since
so here's a math for you
we don't need to know a lot about
complex numbers for this demo
only that they have two parts A and B
called the real and imaginary parts so a
complex number c is actually a sum of a
real part a and an imaginary Part B
times I where I is the square root of -1
they have well-defined operators like
addition and multiplication and they
follow simply from the definition
so
the actual set for some complex number c
we Define a series of complex numbers Z
naught Z1 set two Etc
such that each value of Z equals the
previous value
squared plus C that's
here
now as you repeat this procedure this
iterative function the values of Z that
are produced will either remain small
or
eventually diverge they will run off to
Infinity
if there remains more however many times
you you you you iterate
then C is a member of the mandrel bot
set
sounds simple
but in fact even arbitrarily close
values of c can behave very differently
and this yields an endless complex
variety as we should see
so to visualize it
since complex numbers have two parts
A and B this means that they fit you
know on a plane
you know a coordinate system
with the real part along the horizontal
axis and the imaginary part along the
vertical axis
this is called a complex plane
so what we do is this we run the
iterations for each C for each pixel
if the series doesn't diverge we color
the pixel black that's by Convention of
course it could be any color but that
signifies it's part of the set that's
the interior of the figure there
otherwise we give it another color
depending on how quickly that diverges
so here's some code
the iterate function here takes a
complex number c and the maximum number
of iterations to perform
now we happen to know that if the
modulus of z z exceeds two at any point
the series is going to diverge so that's
our exit condition
the function will return a value between
0 and limit
a return value of limit means that c is
a member of the sets
now
we'll do some codes
I will
I've made a simple WPF application
I'll show you first the CPU version of
this iterator
and then I'll show you the IL GPU
alternative
and uh and what it does for the render
time
so
uh
there we are
good
so
this first here is application code this
is mostly WPF code where you don't need
to worry about it but you can see here
that there's a call to an
iterator.iterate range
now all these parameters that we send in
start width height step
and a palette
that's application code it you can
control it with the mouse and key and so
on you'll see it afterwards but the
point is that having called the iterate
range here
the result of all these situations will
be in a two-dimensional array
and now the actual
we'll have to look at it this double
this complex structure I made first it
has two parts A and B
and it defines these operators
Plus
and multiply
so there's some maths there it also
defines the modulus which is basically
the distance from the origin to the
point in the complex plane it's kind of
the absolute value
of the complex number now for the actual
iterator
this is the CPU iterator
and you recognize the function
it takes a complex number a complex
double
it initializes Z to be
zero and then it runs the loop
and the point is we do this Loop for
every pixel in the image so this is
compute intensive
so for every Loop we Square set and add
C and then
we assign it back to set and then
finally we check the modulus
that's the model is square that saves us
a square root operation and if it's
greater than or equal to 4 then we're
done it's not a member of the set and
finally we return this value and so the
value return will depend on whether it's
in the set or not
or how quickly it diverges
so to do this for all the pixels in the
image we have this iterate range
method it takes a
a starting point
a width and height in pixels of the
image
a step which is basically a scaling
Factor
the maximum number of iterations per
pixel
and a two-dimensional array for the
output and then we simply parallel four
over Y and X
each y and x yields a complex number c
the corresponding complex number for
that pixel
and then we pass it to the iterate
function
and we assign the result to the output
and that's all
the result looks like this
that's on the wrong screen
I'll put it up there
and this is the mandelbrot set
this is all based on that simple
iterative function but you can see it's
really slow the rendering time here is
about half a second
so when I zoom in it's very
somewhat sluggish
it's pretty but it's slow
so
we'll do it in il GPU instead
so this is my GPU iterator
um if we start by
compressing everything you can see that
it has the same thing it has an iterate
function
but it also has some fields
and it's disposable because some of
those fields hold unmanaged resources
so what we basically do here we've
imported the namespaces from IL GPU
we establish a context an IL GPU context
and we create an accelerator
there's lots of very different ways to
do this you can enumerate your devices
and everything but the defaults work
right out of the box
now the iterate function here is a
little bit different because we need the
this is the function that will be run on
your graphics card this is the kernel
and this kernel
needs to do all the work itself so it's
impossible to pass it the actual complex
numbers and stuff so instead we pass it
the X and the Y
for the pixel where are we we send it
the start and the step and the limit
that we had
and it also passes the output buffer to
put the result in
so it's essentially the same only we
calculate C inside here
and then we do exactly the same
iteration we initialize sets we iterate
through them we do the set equals set
squared plus C and so on and then
finally we put the number of iterations
into the output
so how to do this actually on the
graphics card
this is the trick in the Constructor
we create a so-called launcher delegate
we call a method on the accelerator
called load Auto Group stream this is
the simplest most default version way to
do this there's lots of other ways so
you can control this in uh if you really
know what you're doing but the point is
you can see that it has type type
parameters that match the signature of
the iterate function
you can see they're the same and we pass
it a reference to the iterate function
and what this method does is it goes and
fetches the IL for your kernel it
transpiles it into whatever underlying
code the graphics card wants
sends it to the graphics card and then
returns a delegate which you use
to actually run it
and so for the iterate range method that
I had this is the same method that we
had on the CPU iterator
this is the one that's called from my
application code I just switch the
iterator that I use
so what we do here it
just a little bit different
first we allocate a buffer on the
graphics card
we call the method on the accelerator
instance
it's called allocate the width and
height this is a two-dimensional buffer
and then we call the launch delegate
and the first argument to the launch
delegates is this index 2 of width and
height
what we're doing here is we tell IL GPU
and the underlying Cuda or whatever it
is open C help perhaps we tell it please
call my kernel function with all values
between 0 and width and 0 and height
and then we pass it the fixed uh
arguments the start and the step and the
limit and the view to this buffer that
we just allocated on the graphics card
so that the kernel can write to the
buffer
after we've done that we call
accelerator synchronize to wait for it
to finish
and that's
you ladies and gentlemen that's all you
need to do
finally when this is finished the
results are in the buffer we copy the
buffer to the output
array this one
and then we dispose the buffer
so what does that look like
obviously
obviously it looks the same
but now I'll check this little box I
have here to use the GPU accelerator
and you see that the speed is now
something else
so all these they're um
perhaps a few million pixels in each of
these pictures and this point I'm doing
100 iterations for each of them so it's
like 100 million iterations
for each frame
we can also we can change the number of
iterations which will change the
Fidelity of the picture
so if we go in here
we can tune it
and basically you can watch this for
hours this is just fun
I can also change the palette that we
map it onto
binary is boring grayscale is somewhat
less boring
but it's always better with
colors
so that's what I had for you uh go home
and do it yourself it's great fun
foreign